We now have a definite
integral going
from x equals 0 to x
equals square root of pi,
of x sine of x squared dx.
So the first thing that you
might want to ask yourself
is whether u substitution
is appropriate here.
And if it is, what would
you set u to be equal to?
I'll let you think
about that for a second.
Well, we see here this
expression, x squared.
And if we were to just take
the derivative of x squared,
it would be 2x.
We have an x here,
so it's almost a 2x.
To turn this x into 2x we
could multiply it by 2.
But we can't just
only multiply it by 2,
because that would
change the value
of this entire expression.
We'd also have to
multiply by 1/2.
So all I've done so far is I
multiplied by 2 and by 1/2,
which is the same thing
as multiplying by 1.
I have not changed the value of
this entire definite integral.
Now, let's do our
u substitution.
If we set u as
equal to x squared,
we now know that du is
going to be equal to 2xdx.
And so, what can we see here?
Well, we have our u there,
that's how we defined it.
And our du is going
to be 2x times dx.
So this entire
inside, or the thing
that we're taking the integral
of, the definite integral of,
is going to be-- we can rewrite
it as sine of x squared.
But x squared is
just u, so sine of u.
And instead of 2xdx, we
know that 2xdx is now du.
So the thing that we're taking
the integral of in terms of u
could be expressed in this way.
And so we have our integral.
But these boundaries
of integration
were written in terms of x.
We could have written
this as x is equal to 0,
to x is equal to
square root of pi.
Now we want to write
them in terms of u.
And let me not forget that I
had this 1/2 sitting out here.
So how do we write
it in terms of u?
So when x is equal to 0, what
is u going to be equal to?
This boundary is
when x equals 0.
Well, when x is equal to
0, u is also equal to 0.
So this is from u equals zero,
this is the same boundary.
When x is equal to
0, u is equal to 0,
based on how we defined u.
Now what about here?
What is u equal to when x is
equal to the square root of pi?
Well, u is equal to
the square root of pi
squared, let me write this down.
u is going to be equal to the
square root of pi squared, when
x is equal to the square root of
pi, which is just equal to pi.
So this is going to be from
u equals 0, to u equals pi.
I didn't have to explicitly
write this u equals here,
but that makes it a
little bit clearer.
Our boundaries are now
written in terms of u.
And so we are now
ready to evaluate
this indefinite integral.
So this whole thing is going
to be equal to 1/2 times
the expression.
Well, what's the
antiderivative of sine of u?
Well, the derivative
of cosine of u,
let me write it over here.
ddx-- or maybe I should
write in terms of u--
d/du cosine u is equal to
negative sine, negative sine
of u.
So the derivative of
negative cosine of u
is equal to sine of u.
So the antiderivative of sine
of u is negative cosine of u.
And we're going to evaluate
that from, at u equals pi.
And from that we're going to
subtract it, evaluate it at u
equals 0.
u equals 0.
So this is going to be
equal to 1/2 times--
well, what happens when we
evaluate it at u equals pi?
Negative cosine of pi.
Cosine of pi, if we
just-- and I always
have to redraw my unit circles
here-- so cosine of pi.
We're at this point
on the unit circle.
Cosine is the x-coordinate.
Cosine of pi is-- let
me just write it down--
it's going to be
negative cosine of pi.
And then from that, we
are going to subtract
this evaluated when u equals 0.
So minus negative cosine of 0.
Not cosine of theta.
That's what it's
going to be equal to.
And now we're ready
to evaluate it.
Cosine of pi is -1.
But then we have this
negative out front,
so this whole thing
will evaluate to 1.
Cosine of 0.
Cosine of 0 is 1.
And then we're
subtracting a -1, which
is the exact same
thing as adding a 1.
So this whole thing
also becomes a 1.
And so in here we have
1 plus 1 times 1/2.
So this whole thing simplifies
to-- ready for our drum
roll-- 1.
And you see, when we
did u substitution
with a definite
integral, as long
as we changed our
boundaries in terms of u,
we didn't have to go and
then undo the substitution.
We didn't even have to go
and convert back into x.
We were able to evaluate
the definite integral
in terms of u.